hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a 2018 american
science fiction and action movie called
rampage
in 1993 a new technology to treat
incurable diseases through genetic
editing called crispr was invented and
then was quickly misused to develop
dangerous experiments back to the
present day in a space station called
athena 1 a lab rat has been mutated with
crispr and kills the entire crew except
dr carrie atkins
she informs the control room about the
situation of the space station while
going towards the escape capsule
unfortunately the control room refuses
to unlock the capsule and claire wyden
ceo of the responsible biotech company
called energine forces kerry to retrieve
the mutagen samples or she will be left
dead there
she goes back to the wrecked ship and
manages to secure three samples she is
then spotted by the monstrous rat but is
able to get into the escape capsule on
time and departs from athena 1 just
before it explodes with the rat inside
it however the scratch damage caused by
the creature causes the capsule's window
to shatter destroying the entire capsule
and carrying carry instantly
on earth davis okoye a primatologist who
works at san diego wildlife sanctuary
leads nelson amy and connor into a
guerilla enclosure
davies tries to interact with the newest
member of the club pavo who seems still
quite aggressive but he manages to calm
him down with this sign language
suddenly an albino gorilla who has
become davis's best friend for a long
time george comes in which makes conor
panicked and runs away seeing conor
running away pavel runs after him until
george knocks him over despite that
george seems to have a great sense of
humor and likes to make fun of people
davis reminds george to be friendly
towards pavo because the poachers killed
his entire family and he is now an
orphan gorilla davis asks george to do a
fist bump but he gives a middle finger
instead which makes others laugh
as davis drives home that evening the
three canisters which were retrieved by
kerry previously arrive on earth the
first one lands at the gorilla enclosure
spraying george with the gas within it
while the second one lands in the forest
near a pack of wolves and one of them is
exposed with the gas the last one
splashes in a river of the everglades
national park where it is swallowed by a
crocodile the next day davis is told
about georgia's strange behavior who
suddenly invades a grizzly enclosure
upon arrival at the enclosure he's
shocked to see a grizzly has been
cruelly killed by his best friend he
admits that he is the one who
slaughtered the bear and apologizes to
george the gorilla has also surprisingly
become much bigger than yesterday the
team manages to find the canister and
davis recovers it on the other hand
brett claire's brother who is also a
stakeholder at energine is very furious
when he discovers that his mini space
station is completely destroyed and his
company's stock is plunging however
claire seems satisfied and doesn't care
about the money she lost because the
successful mutation proves that the
project rampage experiment is successful
she is also very confident that they
still have hope in the project because
the report from american meteor society
reveals the location of one of the
samples causing her to immediately hire
a private military service to retrieve
the canister before anyone can trace it
back to energi the military team is led
by burke and he and his team is heading
towards wyoming the place where the
second canister was landed upon arrival
burke reports to clear that the canister
is severely damaged and discovers that
all the wolves have been slaughtered
realizing that the remaining wolf is
infected she orders him to capture the
wolf dead or life davie studies the
result of george's blood work and says
that it doesn't make any sense as his
blood has lethal concentration of growth
hormone which can kill him instantly
having heard about the athena one
disaster and news about george escaping
the enclosure on tv
dr kate caldwell former employee of
energine immediately goes to the
sanctuary
there she meets davis and admits that
the canister landed on george's
enclosure as her sample davies allows
her to join the research and she
explains the pathogen inside the
canister works by editing george's gen
causing him to grow rapidly and become
aggressive because she developed the
mutagen she claims that she is the only
one who can cure george from the disease
suddenly george becomes enraged and
eventually breaks out from his cage
storming through the sanctuary and
terrifying all the guests
davis tries to calm him down and orders
the police to lower their gun it works
however a sniper from the helicopter
starts firing tranquilizer darts until
he passes out as they travel deeper into
the forest burke spots the mutated wolf
ralph and manages to shoot him from the
helicopter
they then land to find the presumed dead
wolf's body but discover a massive
wolf's paw print on the ground which
makes them panic a few moments later
ralph starts attacking and begins
eliminating burke's team members one by
one until only burke remains their
weapons even a machine gun from a
helicopter don't work against him
because ralph has developed a
bulletproof skin ralph has also turned
into a very massive and monstrous wolf
that allows him to leap towards the air
and destroy a helicopter
frustrated and cornered burke attempts
to fight the wall for the last time but
is devoured by ralph davies and kate are
arrested and meet agent harvey russell
before being taken aboard the plane that
is transporting george in the plane
russell questions both of them and muses
on davis time with the army's special
forces and the united nations special
anti-poaching task force he then reveals
that kate actually was fired from
energize two years ago after she
attempted to steal the company's hard
drives causing her to be put in prison
for 13 months this fact makes davis
disappointed and doesn't believe in her
anymore because she lied to him and she
admits that she cannot cure george
in the energine office clay recognizes
kate and predicts that she is gathering
evidence to screw them meaning that kate
is a threat to them she also reveals
that the company has actually completed
the cure for the mutated creatures
called r19 which will stop their growth
and reduce their aggression
she then plans to draw all the mutated
creatures to their office by using low
frequency radio waves where the military
will kill them and claire and brett will
have the opportunity to collect their
dna and make money with it
she is also confident that george who is
still on the same plane with kate will
escape from it and kill her eliminating
her as a threat to the company she then
activates the device which makes rolf
suddenly stop wrecking around and starts
running towards the radio wave source
the crocodile who swallowed the canister
earlier is also affected and starts
traveling towards the tower as planned
george despite being sedated suddenly
wakes up destroys the cage and starts
wreaking havoc
people start firing at him with guns but
deal no effect at all towards george
unfortunately someone accidentally
shoots flammable stuff causing it to
explode and destroy the plane's turbine
just before the plane crashes davis
manages to attach parachutes for himself
kate and unconscious russell and eject
themselves from the plane leaving george
inside it george survives the plane
crash and immediately heads towards the
inner giants tower claire learns that
kate also survives the plane crash while
the fbi agents arrive at energine and
request to do a full examination of the
company's records claire wants to put
all the blame on kate thus she tells the
fbi agent that kate is the one who is
responsible for all the chaos happening
right now kate attempts to regain trust
from davis by telling him that she
developed crispr to cure his brother but
the company was secretly using it to
build a weaponized dna she tried to
destroy it but was caught and sent to
prison her brother died while she was in
prison
after hearing that davis is touched and
decides to work together with her again
thanks to russell the three of them are
rescued and brought to the scott air
force base there davey sees footage of
george and ralph running together he
then explains that it is impossible for
two species a gorilla and a wolf to
travel in a straight line to the same
destination kate adds that both of them
are being called by something and cannot
be stopped kate and davis are brought
outside by soldiers but davis manages to
knock them out and with the help from
russell again they escape from the base
by using a helicopter
they are heading to energize hq to steal
the antidote
on the other side the military attempts
to stop the beasts but fail as they wipe
out the entire army because of that the
conal decides to evacuate chicago where
the beasts are heading to and russell
informs that to davis the beasts have
arrived in the city and the military is
overwhelmed to hold their movement even
after using a bunch of tanks and
helicopters a few moments later the
mutated crocodile joins the party and
starts wreaking havoc in the city left
with no options the colonel decides his
crew to prepare the massive bomb which
can wipe out half the city russell tries
to intervene in the decision and tells
him that davis and kate are on their way
to secure the antidote but he rejects
this suggestion because they have stolen
his helicopter the jet that carries the
massive bomb has taken off and is
heading towards the city davis and kate
manages to get inside the hq and find
the antidote but they are spotted by
claire
claire shoots davis in the stomach and
they are forced to hand over the
antidote to her after that they move to
the top of the building leaving davis
alone and taking kate as a hostage just
before they take off george makes it to
the top and smashes the helicopter which
almost kills kate but davis comes on
time and rescues her kate reveals that
she manages to hide an antidote with her
that will be injected to george later
they are confronted by claire but davis
manages to distract her and kate slips
the antidote she has to clear his back
punching her in the face before getting
eaten by the gorilla meanwhile brett who
attempts to escape through the ground
floor meets russell and hands him over
the laptop and the lap rat
after that he runs away but is crushed
by falling debris
while george is already feeling the
effect of the antidote davis and kate
managed to escape from the building with
a broken helicopter just before the
building collapses
thanks to the broken chopper they land
safely and survive
they figure that george has returned to
his normal self and protect them from
the remaining beasts davis orders kate
to find a phone and cause russell to
cancel the airstrike while he equipped
himself with a grenade launcher and
joins the monster fight after the
intense battle between the gorilla and
the wolf the mutated crocodile joins the
battlefield and manages to bite ralph in
his neck and eliminate him kate finally
meets russell and he manages to swap his
lap rat with the soldier's phone that
will be used later to call off the
airstrike
it's now the crocodile vs george but it
seems that george is struggling to beat
it davis helps him by throwing a belt of
grenades into its neck which explode but
the crocodile recovers and tosses the
gorilla against a steel bar that impales
him in the chest as the crocodile
approaches george and prepares to finish
him off davis uses the gunfire and
missiles from the broken helicopter to
distract it because of that the
crocodile goes after davis and nearly
kills him luckily george who equipped
himself with the steeler rebar leaps
into the air and ramps it into the
crocodile's eyes finally killing it
the colonel who sees that the crocodile
has been killed orders to abort the
airstrike mission george fakes his death
which makes dave is very sad while
russell and kate arrive there however
davis catches george's eye twitching and
his hand moving revealing that he is
just fooling around and george gives his
signature middle finger to davis
together they decide to evacuate the
civilians from the city while deciding
where they should place george
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching